I didn't want to miss this opportunity
to be able to tell you a couple of stories
that I hope you might enjoy.
The first one is about the town
where I come from.
It's called Port Talbot in South Wales.
It's sort of, I guess,
famous for a couple of things.
It's got a steelworks.
It's a sort of mainly working-class town
built up around the steelworks,
big council estate
to house the workers there
that my grandparents grew up on
and my parents grew up on as well.
And it's also, I suppose,
known for, weirdly, actors.
And I said that this story
was going to be about the town.
It's actually about a couple of people
who come from the town.
So this first story was told to me,
it's from the horse's mouth.
So one of the legendary sons
of Port Talbot
is of course, the great
actor Richard Burton.
And the story goes
that Richard Burton,
at the height of his fame,
came back to Port Talbot
and was staying at his elder
sister's house, Cissy,
who actually raised him in Port Talbot.
And they were there,
in Cissy's house in Port Talbot,
and there was a knock on the door
and Cissy went to open the door.
And it was a young, young lad.
And he said, this young lad said,
"Is, is Richard Burton there?"
And Cissy was like,
"Richie, come, there's
a lad here to see you."
So Richard Burton comes down
and this young lad's
standing there looking at him,
"It's the great Richard Burton."
And Cissy says, "This young lad
wants an autograph."
And Burton said, "Do you speak Welsh?"
The lad was like, "No."
"Well, not a proper Welshman then."
And Cissy says,
"This little lad is the son
of the bakers round the corner,
down from where the Regent Cinema is."
And Burton said to this little lad,
"I used to work at the co-op
just up the road from the cinema.
I was hopeless."
And this little lad couldn't believe
that he got his autograph.
And this little lad grew up
into a man who told me
that not only was this
an extraordinary moment for him,
because it was Richard Burton
who was doing on the biggest stage
what he hoped that he would do
when he grew up,
but also because this
little lad felt like --
he was always told he was a bit stupid,
a bit “twp,” as we’d say in Wales.
And Richard Burton,
the great Richard Burton,
saying that he was always
a bit hopeless as well,
gave him such hope.
Now, that little lad grew up
to be Anthony Hopkins.
And Anthony Hopkins told me that story
and I, me, myself,
growing up in Port Talbot,
it was knowing out there
had been Richard Burton
and out there now was Anthony Hopkins,
two people who came
from the same town as me,
who sounded like me a bit,
who looked a bit like me,
but were out there.
If it was possible for them,
then maybe it would be possible for me.
Now, that is an incredibly
important thing.
To see your background,
your experience, your history
represented out there in the world,
having a voice, speaking on a platform,
doing the things that perhaps you hope
that you would be able to do.
If you can't see yourself out there
or anyone who looks like you
or sounds like you,
it's very hard to imagine
that you'll be able to do that as well.
And that’s one part of what
was incredibly important,
I've realized over the years,
of what was incredibly important
about me being able
to have the life and the opportunities
and the career that I've had.
But it's only one part.
I've realized more and more
as time has gone on
how much I owe
everything, all the opportunities
I've had, to other people
and the work of other people.
I come from an incredibly
supportive family.
All my family were into
performing in some way,
amateur performing in some way,
so I knew from a very early age
that it was something that you could do
and that you got, sort of,
brownie points for.
So that was important.
And as time went on,
my family were always there to take me
to school rehearsals in the evening,
youth theater, whatever it might be.
They'd come and see me
in any performance I was doing,
and that meant a lot.
It's meant a lot more to me
as time has gone on,
because, of course, I took
everything for granted,
didn't I, at the time.
But having that supportive family
was incredibly important.
And coming from a community,
a working-class community,
like Port Talbot, a steel town,
it's not somewhere that you would expect
to be that supportive of people
going into the poncy arts, you know.
But Richard Burton had done it,
Anthony Hopkins had done it,
and there was a kind of nobility to it.
There was certainly a respectability to it
and a respect for what they had done.
And so that made a big difference.
But in some ways, I think
the most important part
was that I was able to do performances
in school, drama in school,
and then I auditioned
for a youth theater, local youth theater.
It was the county youth theater.
And again, at the time
I took it all for granted.
But now I look back and I can see
that there was an incredibly ...
powerful youth arts infrastructure
that had grown up in the area.
Not by chance.
It hadn't happened randomly.
It was because one man,
man called Godfrey Evans,
who was a teacher at
the Comprehensive School
on the Sandfields estate,
that was the estate that housed
the steelworkers families,
he had created an incredibly
kind of, progressive, liberal
theater program
in that comprehensive school
and eventually that spread
to the entire county.
And he became
the chief adviser of county ...
of drama and dance in the county
and created the youth theater
that I was a product of,
that Russell T. Davies
was a product of, many, many people.
The youth dance company that
Catherine Zeta-Jones was a product of,
the orchestra, the brass band.
It was an incredible diverse array of art,
all funded through the education system.
And I was absolutely a product of that.
And I joined the youth theater.
And at a certain point,
everyone in our youth theater
just auditioned for drama schools,
got in, went off to drama
schools in London,
went into the profession.
I never questioned it.
I didn't think that was strange
or odd in any way.
It was just like, that's what happened.
And so that's what I did.
And I got a grant to be able
to go to RADA in London
and came to RADA and then left RADA,
went straight into the West End
doing a play with Vanessa Redgrave,
never looked back.
As time has gone on,
I've seen that pathway,
let's call it, disappear.
So I know that if I was around now,
starting off, that pathway
wouldn't be there.
And I had tremendous advantages,
I realize now,
with family, community,
all kinds of things.
And it does make me worry
that not only has my pathway disappeared,
my school stopped doing drama,
school closed down eventually,
the youth theater lost its funding.
Grants weren't available anymore
for people to go to drama school.
So I've seen my footsteps
kind of disappear.
And if someone like myself,
with all the advantages I had,
wouldn't be able to do it,
what about the kids who are out there
who don’t have those advantages,
who don't have maybe a family
who can take them
to youth theater rehearsals
or you know, whatever it might be.
Don't have a school that pushed them,
don’t have that kind of
infrastructure there
to create that pathway for them,
what happens to them?
And then that leads
to a bigger question, I suppose,
of, if young people,
coming from certain kinds
of working-class backgrounds,
aren't able to come through into the arts,
I mean, I was an actor,
but it could be anything
within the arts or creative industries
or journalism, writing.
The conversation
that we have as a country,
as a nation, as a community,
what is that conversation like
if we're only hearing from the people
who are able to afford to get through
to the point where they get to speak,
get to have a voice?
It makes that conversation
incredibly one-sided.
I mean, there are figures
that I can quote you
that I'll just keep to a few.
But the Office of National Statistics
reported a few years back
that of all writers in Britain,
47 percent
came from the most
privileged social starting points,
compared to 10 percent
coming from working-class backgrounds.
The Sutton Trust report in 2019
said that of newspaper columnists --
so these are people
who've really got a big part to play
in setting what our
national conversation is,
newspaper columnist across
the political spectrum --
44 percent of those
newspaper columnists
come from independent schools,
whereas only seven percent
of the population generally
go to independent schools.
So there’s a massive
overrepresentation there.
And of those newspaper columnists,
33 percent, one in three,
are part of that independent school,
Oxbridge, pathway pipeline.
And those are the people
who are, you know,
have an enormous part to play in setting
what our conversation is.
You know, who gets to speak,
who gets to tell their story
and how does it get told.
And if that pathway is there
for people coming through independent
schools and through Oxbridge,
and that's not just
into acting or writing,
that's across the top jobs
across our whole nation,
where are those other pathways
for people who are not coming
from those sorts of backgrounds?
It's so important that we start early
to create those pathways.
In some ways, I feel like it's too late
by the time you're 18, 19
out in the world.
How do you get people,
young people, young kids,
to feel like there's something
out there for them,
that they see themselves represented
and know that it's possible,
as Anthony Hopkins did
with Richard Burton, as I did with them?
And how do you then create
the pathway from that moment?
And let's say that that moment happens
where you see the possibility
for you doing something.
Where is that yellow brick road
that goes from there
all the way to actually getting
into the industry that you want to be in?
If that pathway doesn't exist,
because it certainly exists
for some people,
but it doesn't exist for you
because of some accident
of birth and geography,
what happens then?
There will always be individuals
who are able to break through in some way
or get support and become
the exception to the rule.
But how do we change
structurally our system
so that it's not just
about individuals breaking through,
that everyone gets the same opportunity?
So I found myself sitting
at my kitchen table
during the first lockdown,
talking to Professor Katy Shaw
about a project that she
had been involved with,
that I was incredibly inspired by,
the Common People project.
I suddenly had a grandiose vision
of supporting people
coming from working-class backgrounds,
underrepresented backgrounds,
in storytelling.
And we started to hammer out
an idea for a project
that could go out into communities
and towns and look for those people.
We started to think about a project
where people were given the opportunity,
asked to get involved
and that were then supported through it
and would get mentors.
So people who've already made
a mark in the industry
and the areas that they wanted to,
helping them, supporting them,
advising them, giving them
a bit of confidence
and then to create a platform
for what came out of it
to be shared nationally
and to try and influence industry.
And, whether it's publishers or, you know,
broadcasters or whoever it might be,
to open their doors.
And first of all, to acknowledge
the difficulties and the obstacles
and then encourage people to come in.
To renew us,
to hear voices that we've not
heard from historically.
And to hear of those experiences
and those stories
told by themselves
rather than having their story
told at them or to them.
That people are able
to actually tell their own stories.
And we believed that that would be
an incredibly powerful thing,
not only for the individuals
involved, but for all of us.
And so A Writing Chance was born
through that conversation, really.
We have 11 people eventually
who got through to be our first cohort
who would go through the program
and get mentoring
and get the financial support
and everything else.
And I remember reading
Stephen Tuffin's piece
that he submitted,
which was about ...
caring for his mother in her final days.
And I remember thinking,
not only is this one
of the most moving things
I've read in these submissions,
this is one of the most
moving things I've ever read.
It was an extraordinary,
searing, incredibly raw,
beautiful piece of writing.
And in that moment,
I knew that this was going
to exceed all expectations.
And it did.
The 11 writers that we finally
worked with for the last year,
reading what they've done
has been absolutely revelatory.
Whether it's reading about the experience
of marginalized bodies by Grace Quantock.
Lifting the veil on what it is like
to live with a disability
and how people relate to that.
It's extraordinary.
Everything she's written
has been extraordinary.
Stephen's piece, about caring
for his mother in her final days ...
I will never forget that piece.
It will stay with me
for the rest of my life.
There's David Clancy,
hairdresser in Ulverston,
talking about how he turned
having gibes thrown at him
for being gay when he was younger,
being kicked out
of his own house by his parents
for being gay
and then having to move
back into the house with his mum,
or choosing to move back into the house
with his mother and father,
as the pandemic struck,
in order to look after them.
That experience.
Whether it's Maya Jordan,
coming to write her novel
about the goddess of the River Severn.
These are incredible pieces of writing
from and with voices and experiences
that I just never heard before.
It's absolutely revelatory to me.
To see their writing in a magazine,
on a national newspaper,
being performed live on stage,
being broadcast
on BBC Sounds in a podcast.
This is extraordinary stuff.
I remember Maya Jordan telling me
that -- the idea of being
a writer on her estate,
she said, "There were no
writers on our estate.
To say to someone
that you wanted to be a writer
was like saying you wanted
to be an astronaut."
It was amazing to be able to go up to Maya
after the live performance
that we did in Cardiff.
And to say to us all,
"How does it feel to be an astronaut?"
(Music)